تواصل القوات الاوكرانيه هجومها المضاد
حيث نفذت ضربه صاروخيه على المقر العام
للاسطول الروسي في البحر الاسود والواقع
في وسط مدينه سيباسبول في القرم شن العدو
هجوما صاروخيا على المقر العام للاسطول في
البحر الاسود يجري تحديد حصيله الضحايا
المحتملين وهناك احتمال بوقوع هجوم
اوكراني اخر
وزاره دفاع روسيه كانت قد اعلنت في وقت
سابق عن تدمير طائرتين مسيرتين قرب الساحل
القرم وفي منطقه توابس باقليم كريسنودار
الهجمات تتواصل ايضا على جبهه بخمود التي
استهدفتها القوات الاوكرانيه بقصف عنيف
وصفه رئيس العمليات العسكريه الروسيه في
المنطقه بالفوضوي
خلال ال 24 ساعه الماضيه نفذ العدو عددا
من العمليات في اتجاه الايمان ونفض
استطلاعا قتاليا في عده اتجاهات دفعه
واحده
تقعديمان على مسافه قريبه جدا من خط
المواجهه على بعد 50 كيلومترا غرب لسيد
تشانسسك وهما مدينتان تحت السيطره الروسيه
المنطقه الصناعيه عانت من وطاه القتال منذ
الهجوم الروسي وتعد معركه باخموت الاطول
والاكثر دمويه الصراع من جهه اخرى قالت
الشركه المشغله للطاقه في اوكرانيا ان
هجمات صاروخيه روسيه الحقت اضرارا بالبنيه
التحتيه للط في وسط وغرب اوكرانيا وتسببت
في انقطاعات للكهرباء في خمس مناطق رئيس
الوزراء الاوكراني ادان استئناف روسيا ما
وصفه بارهاب الطاقه من خلال مهاجمه البنيه
التحتيه الاساسيه مع اقتراب فصل الشتاء